c'est grave déjà prometteuse et ce
terroir des rives du cher donneront
bientôt naissance au nouveau millésime
de 15,6 à vin frais et vif ce partage
avec le champagne et le châteauneuf du
pape le privilège d'avoir été l'une des
premières à hausser française c'était en
1936 il y avait beaucoup beaucoup de
travaux faits main chaque vigneron était
un petit peu polyculteur parce que tout
le travail se faisait avec un cheval
avant vous travaillez tout avec une
charrue alors le dessous du rang il
fallait tout le fer à la main
c'était un travail monstre ça raymond a
aussi bien connu les années difficiles
d'après guerre où les jeunes préféraient
partir à la ville que de travailler
courbet dans les vignes de quincy la
renaissance du vignoble n'a eu lieu que
dans les années 80 grâce à une nouvelle
génération
je suis la troisième génération et je
suis revenue aux vignes depuis 1985 le
travail c'était de racheter les vieille
vigne et de replanter parce qu'il y
avait beaucoup il y avait beaucoup des
vignes à cassis aujourd'hui le vignoble
consulte considérablement rajeuni en
s'agrandissant s'est considérablement
rajeuni quincy a aujourd'hui trouvé sa
place sur les cartes de restaurants où
il accompagne à merveille les fruits de
mer il s'exporte bien et si vous vous
demandez quelle est la différence avec
d'autres blancs du centre comme le
sancerre on vous répondra par le mot
terroir
on a beaucoup de vignes qui sont plantés
sur sable alors le soleil par une
réverbération sur les petits grains de
sable qui font glace le raisin prend
autant de soleil par en dessous par
dessus 100% blanc 100% cépages sauvignon
c'est dans ces conditions que le
président albert lebrun signal a aussi
dû 1936 mais à quincy on ne désespère
pas d'obtenir enfin une appellation pour
le rouge et le rosé parole de vignerons
au choix